[Music]
all right this is kind of a conspiracy
corner that's adjoined all right I hate
it you know like it's basically it's not
hailing she was not supposed to be part
of it anymore
how I need a little backup from you
Steve because I'm hoping that out of
everybody here you are the one that know
what this is what is it
have you heard of American Stonehenge
yes Oh Americans the one who may use the
colorful rocks no no it's called the
Georgia stones Joe I already believe in
it 100%
oh I've never heard of it okay but no
all right so it's a monument with the
instructions for the post apocalypse
I believe in 110 percent okay so this is
what it looks like
no one knows shut up this is when did it
appear so the Georgia Guidestones
it's written in many different languages
right so it's huge slabs of granite
inscribed with directions for rebuilding
civilization after the apocalypse
so only one man knows who created them
and he's not talking so there's five
massive slabs of polished granite and
it's risen on the [ __ ] I don't know
it's it's it's it's it's a star pattern
there's sixteen feet tall four of them
weighing more than 20 tons of piece they
support a 25,000 pound capstone it's
[ __ ] huge right so to get an idea
this muhfucka let me get you a good
picture it looks like too much time look
at this [ __ ] you guys see this - yeah -
yeah one two three four and a pillar in
the middle and then a [ __ ] big-ass
stone right here how many piles how tall
16 feet oh I don't know what that's like
three basketball players all right yeah
where's that Georgia I think so I called
it a Georgia Guidestones so I'm assuming
it's in Georgia talking like Atlanta
Georgia I hope and not the Russian train
George yeah
no it's in America oh yeah I believe it
was in actual Georgia yeah that would be
sicker actually because when something
is more reason it's not a sex
yeah like hearing that that just got
dropped there's not a sexy is like oh
they unearthed it from 500 years ago 3
yeah if we wait a 500 years and do a JK
news on it then bury that [ __ ] and then
it's interesting yeah so it's me do they
talk I did he talked about like in the
the things did they talk about like how
to recreate the internet and [ __ ]
because if I don't have a cell phone and
all that [ __ ] like I don't know want to
live I don't know man I didn't read that
much I didn't do my homework but what I
do be Wi-Fi is it's written in Spanish
so all these different sides every
single like plus side of the stone it's
written in different language is awesome
English there's Russian I carried that
Chinese Arabic Hebrew Sanskrit Hindi
Swahili classical Greek Egyptian
hieroglyphics Babylonian cuneiform
Spanish and English it's improper like
those languages like if you write it in
proper Spanish or just Google Translate
because that one guy that did all of
them cuz if you didn't tell anyone like
to translate it right right so how does
he know yeah he might have did it on
Google like Babel Fish or whatever
[ __ ] it doesn't have Vietnamese what's
it man alien of granite yeah yeah yeah
granite
yeah Wow so then not only does it have
an instructions for how to rebuild the
future it also functions as a clock a
calendar and a compass sick but you got
to know how to [ __ ] read it it's just
army knife yeah that's cool man this
[ __ ] nut I'm like stone henges has no
[ __ ] utility at all what are they
claim Stonehenge to being or some [ __ ]
that's a star man I feel like statues
that have compasses in it it's not a big
deal because it used me to point in one
direction and it kind of stays that way
forever true I mean every statue is a
compass that's true if you think about
it as long as you leave my reality dude
I thought it was way more complex it's
like one of the things that says to on
how to rebuild he didn't do his homework
I'm reading it right now there's a lot
of reading
you guys read it yeah I'm gonna leave
the link in below it's very interesting
I'm kind of like learning about this but
I just wanted to share with you right we
never think about that she apart easily
exactly I don't want to think about it
but this person really put some thought
into this [ __ ]
I want the apocalypse happened you want
to watch it's wrong what you do not
survive more than most yeah but you're
never gonna be able to jack off the porn
ever again the Internet's done yeah but
my creativity in my mind is pretty good
we're getting a soft pocalypse right now
you think that's real fine yes okay you
think this is fun right now I guess they
all might go to create I got to make
money but then I'll race all those
things no there's literally a hundred
more you talked to me he loves the
apocalypse he's like I can stay home I
have a job and fine like I love the
public yeah but what I'm saying is once
the actual popular I have guns I have
everything I need
I can go you run really slow other
people with guns everything has to be
structure and as mutants yes talk about
[ __ ] mutant mutant bicycle riders
dude
can we can we kill you coming to
agreement what kind of a cop no I like
that one yeah they're gonna be around
yeah yeah
so there's killer tomatoes and mutants
on in this apocalypse it's you don't
think Tomatoes won't revenge against
what we've done to them yeah well with
the catalyst nuclear warfare
yeah fallout fallout okay okay Eli we'll
go in uh bunkers that nobody's but yet
for like twenty years thirty years don't
think they know the bunkers that we need
to go on - oh okay okay can you have one
in mine already
you know one yeah fallout three I based
my own knowledge off of that game oh
yeah you guys could do one really cheap
we just get a container bury it that's a
fallout shelter right there yeah doesn't
need ventilation enough yard to bury it
yes and put a door on top we just have a
straw long straw that goes up to there
but make sure it's bendy yeah so you can
twist it and go like that but it's a
metal bendy straw so we say the virus
very
the turtles do Oh metal band Eva that's
true always live underwater we all
breathe through straws Girl Talk though
that [ __ ] [ __ ] scares me like I can't
think about [ __ ] like that cuz I'm just
like I don't know how close we are to
[ __ ] like that cuz like we don't have
all the knowledge that like the
government has and like we don't know
what's really out there so like that's
why it's good to live in fear and be
prepared I like the uncertainty of it
all - because it's like there's hope
with it you know if you know for certain
that an apocalypse is coming you know it
for certain you don't know when yeah you
don't know but like but if you know
something for certain it kind of sucks
those hope out of it you know it's so
optimistic and dark at the same you like
the fact it's a surprise that's I don't
believe in like going to see like
fortune tellers or like reading my
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] I'm like we do is
[ __ ] like we go to work we do this
we do that it's just for what to make a
little money
no not Barbeau but everything else yeah
but it's like just would be much more
fun than going to work yeah and then all
this of the actually where you could
actually make good connections you know
the bad people you just kill him
you know like so odd hi you wearing
corduroy pants boom and then green ones
that's the colors of nineteen years yeah
it was this year I'm just like you just
feed out the bad and then the good
survive yeah so there's some parts of
the world that feels like all out like
apocalypse like when there's a war
happening right so some people say
that's a tragedy I say that's
opportunity because sometimes I do wish
for a situation where there's government
instability because then that gives me
opportunity to run it so yeah I mean
like just to make your way all the way
where government is and that's like
thousands and thousands and thousands of
miles away it's gonna take you like
months to go you make your own way yeah
I mean Castro was Cuban nope
he was like Colombian or something I
didn't know
ha check Vivaro and Castro were like
South American dudes that said let's go
to Cuba and liberate it from the Mafia
because the Mafia was running Cuba like
Las Vegas and the American government
was just using Cuba and destroying that
land and the locals were like hey we
can't have our daughters be prostitutes
and all these guys be servants to all
these hotel owners that are just [ __ ]
raping our people and then the
Communists came in and they kicked them
out that's what happened that's what I
would've been so sick if the u.s. won
the Vietnam War and you got Richard
Nixon in Vietnam and he's like he's like
we are the Vietnamese people that's what
I wanted to happen if we would have had
the Luxor in Vietnam right now we would
have had we would have American casinos
there yeah and the donkey showed me the
Colombian guys like for Cuba it's like
hey Benjy you're not Cuban are you
vacuuming not so fast
or maybe he's Mexican I don't know
Americans like Mexican Cuban yeah don't
call me on it but I know they're not
local but Jaguar I think he was the
Colombian I don't know but they had they
went to Cuba to liberate it don't quote
us on many things yeah yeah yeah I got
my hat's mixed up man I don't know you
guys have Wikipedia right there just
search it up and correct me the daddy
likes to drink a little too much on this
oh I feel like the apocalypse it really
depends right because if it's a zombie
apocalypse I might be cool with it
wait why they're gonna eat you now
there's stupid well if it's the wine to
zombies yeah not [ __ ] World War Z
those fools are crazy swimming zombies
dude that could happen the ones that
climb on top of each other Wars II yeah
those are crazy and they're fast I am
Legend one started learning patterns and
then like really that's when they came
to the I am so what the really slow I
like the walking yeah yeah yeah yeah and
in reality I think like it just takes
three days for them to all die anyway
you're just gonna kick it corn today in
real life yeah zombies would die to me
really quickly yeah their body would be
alive I don't
Poussin zombies that ridiculous doesn't
go with the flu I just want to play if
we're playing nice like this give me
give me that give me the cumin shorts
now that's some real [ __ ]
can't believe these people are talking
about zombies I was wanting to talk
about real things why don't you want an
excuse to shoot guns off your watch just
curious about where you got the number
three doesn't matter what's the way we
said the number three days of their
bodies will decompose within three days
so if they're dead
yeah it's about three days that they
don't follow as well okay in real life
parasites that infest like living
animals and is literally their dead but
they're still moving right but the
animals aren't technically dead they're
still alive they're just brain function
and everything is being controlled by
the parasite yeah right to go and fess
the rest of the people or the rest of
the gotta kill the parasite that's what
you're saying
yeah whatever in fact see zombies so
technically they're not decomposing not
dead but yeah they're dumb and they
can't find food and they're just in the
Sun and the cat find shelter they'll
eventually die zombie rules are we
following on this [ __ ] because he thinks
that zombies would die in five days I
don't think you've thought this through
because zombies have strengthened
numbers there are many numbers of
zombies true then they feed on each
other thank you then what if they eat on
each other's yeah they do eat on a
journey together you don't poop they
don't run out of energy see the real
question is can you get zombie virus
like contracted through st like vinyl
sites like make zombie slaves muzzling a
zombie yeah hot zombie muzzle her right
yeah what if her arms fall off while
you're [ __ ] her that's kinky Brown oh
man I grabbed her army source matter
with it
and then I call the World Health
Organization yeah I think we have a
sixteen tachi yeah I'm like hey how're
you there I'm like that's poppy him go
oh that's true that could be him now
he's like I guess I'll call back